-Nicole, I thought
it'd be fun to play a game
to see how well
we know each other.
You in?
-Yes.
-Okay, good. Now --
-Yes, I'm definitely in.
I'm excited.
-Yeah, good.
Here's how this works.
[ Laughter ]
It's just like
"The Newlywed Game"
where we try to match
each other's answers,
but we've never even dated,
so --
[ Laughter ]
So it might be --
It might be harder.
It might be a bit harder.
This is "The Neverwed Game."
Here we go.
-Hell nah!
♪ The Neverwed Game ♪
-Nicole, this is going
to be fun, I think.
Now, some of these
questions will be about me,
some of these questions
will be about you,
and we'll both write down
our answers in secret.
If the answers match,
we get a point.
-Okay. Yes.
-Nicole, this first question
is about you.
Nicole Kidman,
what is your biggest fear?
-Uh, my biggest fear,
'cause I have a lot.
-I know.
I think this is one of them.
You can write three of them
if you want.
I have one of them, I think.
-Okay, just hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
-My gosh.
-Oh, God.
I'm taking it too seriously.
-Me?
I-I'm having fun here.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Uh, well, don't -- Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, God. Okay.
Just do it.
-Alright, ready for this?
-No.
-No, 3 --
-I've put nothing.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing.
[ Applause ]
-No, the game works like this.
You have to put something.
What is one of your biggest
fears, just your biggest fear?
Doesn't have to be --
-I have no fear.
-Alright, okay.
-None.
-How about --
-There. It's there.
-Sharks.
Sharks.
-No, that is so wrong.
You are so wrong.
[ Buzzer ]
-You live -- You're from
Australia. There's like --
-Because I love sharks.
I love sharks.
I've scuba dived with sharks,
and I love sharks.
-No, you said, "I love sharrks."
And your real accent
is "shawks."
-Shawk.
-"I love shawks."
-Shawks.
-Yeah, you said sharks.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
sometimes I roll my R's
because I have to play American.
But I'm now Australian,
and I love shawks.
-Well, you might love sharks,
but you don't like shawks.
Okay, alright.
-There, look.
-So we're 0 for 1.
-I mean, come on.
No fear.
-Come on. That's how you play?
"No fear" --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
That's a meme right there.
Okay. This next one is --
-[ Laughs ]
-Nicole, this next one
is about me. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Which -- Which Disney character
am I the most like?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, I have no idea.
Which Disney character.
Wait, hold on.
[ Laughter ]
Are you showing it?
Are you showing it right now?
Don't --
[ Applause ]
Don't show it yet.
-I can't help it.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, I said --
-I'm excited by it.
-I said Mickey Mouse.
Don't say Goof--
-I said Little Mermaid.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Little Mermaid.
[ Laughter ]
-I remind you
of the Little Mermaid?
-Yeah!
-Oh, my --
-So cute.
-Oh! My gosh.
[ Both giggling ]
You are unbelievable, man.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright. Alright.
Here we go. This one --
[ Giggles ]
This one is about you, okay?
Here we go.
Is your go-to karaoke song
"Mamma Mia" by ABBA
or "You Shook Me All Night Long"
by AC/DC?
-Oh.
-Is your go-to karaoke song --
It's one of these two, I guess.
-Do I have to answer
one of those two?
-Yes.
You have to play the game
at one point.
-Okay.
-Gosh.
-"Shook Me --"
-I think I know the answer
to this one.
♪♪
Mm, maybe not.
-I --
-Oh.
-No, ready?
1, 2, 3.
-You're funny.
Go.
-Okay.
My writing is so bad.
-Yes! I think we got one!
[ Ding ]
AC/DC!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-See?
-But that --
I would have chosen "Mamma Mia,"
but I actually prefer
"You Shook Me All Night Long."
-Yeah, I-I got that,
and I know I love AC--
I knew that you
would rock AC/DC.
-I love AC/DC.
-Me, too. Me, too.
I love AC/DC.
-I love AC/DC.
-I knew it!
I knew it, I knew it.
We got one right. This is big.
-But I love ABBA,
but I love AC/DC.
-This one's weird.
This one's about me --
-You're ignoring me!
[ Laughter ]
-No, I heard you.
You said you love AC/DC.
-Okay.
-No, I --
-But you didn't, like,
really kind of take that
and run with it.
-No, I did take it
The only reason I didn't
elaborate is because I know --
-Because you're like,
"Who cares?"
-No, I --
[ Laughter ]
I love --
I love that you love that.
I think people would think
"Mamma Mia," but I know you,
and I think Australia and AC/DC,
they're like royalty there.
-Yeah.
-They're Australian.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Alright, here we go.
This next one is...
-Yeah.
-Which one of us is most likely
to get a tattoo?
Me or you?
♪♪
Yeah, I got this.
Me. I know that.
Yeah. I would never get one.
I would never get a tattoo.
But I know that you --
I feel like
you would never get a tattoo.
-Yeah, I would never-never.
-Yeah, me, too.
-'Cause if we would both never,
somebody has to be never-never.
-Yeah, I think
you're never-never --
Yeah, I could, like, maybe
be tricked into maybe --
-You're like maybe
10 shots and...
[ Laughter ]
...a million bucks.
-Yeah, I was just thinking,
I would just get maybe like --
If I got a tattoo,
I'd get a freckle.
-A freckle?
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
-That's what I would get, yeah.
-No, well, then,
I would get a freckle.
I actually, if that was
a choice, I'd get a freckle.
-Would you?
-Yeah, I like fre--
A mole, a mole.
-Oh --
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "What?"
-A mole.
-You know, there, I love that,
that Cindy Crawford mole.
-Yes, no, I love that one, too,
Marilyn, Cindy, yeah.
You would do that in the face?
-Yeah, I would get it.
-Alright, this is
for the whole win.
So far, we've done well.
-Right.
So far, who is winning?
It's very, very confusing.
-It turns out that this is
a team game is what it --
I don't think we were playing
against each other at all.
So we're playing
with each other.
[ Laughter ]
-I like it. It's fun.
-Yeah, this is fun. Alright --
-More!
-This last one is a two-parter.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to
answer it for you,
and then we're going
to answer it for me.
Which emoji do you use the most?
So, put two emojis
on your thing, for you.
Put one for you first
and then one for me.
-Oh, right.
-I know the answer.
-Oh.
I wouldn't have a clue
what emoji you use,
but I'm going to do mine,
but I don't have the right pen.
I do that.
Oh, I'll do yours.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You ready?
-It's --
-Wait.
We did it!
Did we do it?
[ Ding ]
-No, no. Mine has the --
It's you blowing a kiss.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, I'm blowing a kiss.
I thought I was happy.
Alright, good.
Alright, I'll do both.
That's our pal right there.
-Wow!
-That is Nicole Kidman.
-That's phenomenal.
We were very, very in sync.
-Can you stay
for the whole show?
Check out the finale
of "Nine Perfect Strangers"
tomorrow on Hulu.